a secret private military organization
that operates on an unknown agenda the
black tusks are disciplined and highly
organized group of elite soldiers
cutting-edge equipment and robotic
weapons they're the biggest threat that
the division has ever faced
[Music]
you
it's been seven months it's the initial
green poison outbreak when an attack on
the shd Network shuts down the system
controlling their advanced technology
communications division agents receive a
distress call from Washington DC upon
arriving in the capital the agents find
much of the city is under the control of
three main enemy factions the hyenas are
loosely organized group of several gangs
the outcasts a fanatical group seeking
revenge and the true sons a highly
organized and ruthless group of former
JTF personnel the division worked day
and night to liberate the city and
eventually managed to push the factions
into the respective strongholds and take
them out one by one however as the
division celebrate their victory a new
technologically advanced group rolls in
and invades the city this was the
invasion of the black tusk the black
Tusker a private military contractor who
had been brought into Washington by an
unnamed employer Barden Schaffer is the
black tusk specialist unit leader he is
directly below the black tusk commanding
officer and another supervisor their
identities are unknown burdens family
has a history and law enforcement and
government security he enlisted at the
age of 18 and served multiple tours of
Iraq and Afghanistan he proved to be
highly tactical and had the ability to
eliminate targets with extreme
efficiency shortly after the outbreak in
New York the black tusks were approached
and hired by a mysterious organization
they see that the chaos in New York is
only the beginning and that when the
time is right they want to exploit the
disorder and breakdown of society when
it hits the capital Barton was ordered
by his superiors to create a black tusk
specialist unit
and it still tastes like dirt what's
happening in New York it's just the
beginning yeah no [ __ ] I want you to put
together a team I already have a team a
bigger team more diversified for what
for whatever it takes we have an
opportunity here golden one but we have
to be smart we have to act fast so no
choir boys is what you're saying I'm
saying scoundrels and scum all right
killers and cutthroats I don't give a
[ __ ] as long as they follow orders and
can get [ __ ] done all right I'll get to
work work fastest [ __ ] nine button
set off to work sibling his new
specialist forces unit he can even be
seen talking to a decent Sawyer we said
it was a cockroach
I assumed she meant that was tough to
kill I might do introductions after
you've heard me out so hush-hush
what aren't you these days oh gee eh
that's what I wanted to talk to you
about I've got a new employer we're
hiring good base plus hazard paying
bonuses and you'd be working with
quality people yeah who would I be
working for people who want what's best
for this country this is a one-time deal
Oh Dustin things are happening fast you
don't want to miss this bus I swore an
oath and I'm sticking to it not
something I expect a cockroach to
understand well damn shame sure would be
an asset be seeing you
with the task of gaining control of the
city they waited until the controlling
factions of the city had been weakened
before launching a full-scale invasion
seizing control of the u.s. capital part
of the mission to take control of
Washington DC was to eliminate the
division a man who can only assume as
the leader of the black tusk can be seen
in the trailer ordering his men to
eliminate all division agents with
extreme prejudice
the division has been targeted as the
only worthwhile resistance that the city
has to offer but they were to be treated
as a rogue agency so from day one they
were listed as the first target for the
black tusk strategic homeland division
now considered a rogue agency that must
be brought to heel civilian militias and
remnants of the three dominant factions
active within the area of operations
must disarm and submit to the rule of
law or they will be classified as
insurgent groups and dealt with
accordingly we have seen little evidence
that anyone in this [ __ ] of a city
intends to play nice first button and
his officers discuss the challenges
around going to war with the division
they have a plan for crippling the
network and taking down the agents one
by one there are no survivors so what
does that mean for us a new plan and a
new enemy division bingo then we need to
do something about their advantages
that's the new plan where are we
supposed to get that kind of Intel we
already have it I got a list of key
targets right here we're seriously going
after the division we are seriously
going after them and we are going after
them seriously we are gonna gag them
blind them kick them in the nuts and
steal their lunch money this is gonna be
fun we finally agree on something
and a stand-up fight a couple of
division agents ain't nothin don't worry
about the problem is getting them in a
stand-up fight they're crafty [ __ ]
they've got a vulnerability same one
anybody has when they're trying to
protect something
there are also traitors among them that
we can use to our advantage the first
step is to [ __ ] their network that'll
expose them make them weak and we start
picking them off the action of taking
down the sh t network communications is
what brought additional agents to the
Washington DC it's unclear whether this
was intended or not the black continued
with the mission of hunting division and
doing your job is never a waste of time
especially if you deal with pride and
conviction save us both some
unpleasantness but Nana's officers could
be seen early on in the conflict to
gather Intel for the upcoming engagement
they've been lying in the shadows
monitoring the status of Washington DC
preparing for the city shut the hell up
some of us are working here you call
staring at the [ __ ] white house
working it's the opposite of working
nobody ever sets the famous is supposed
to be fun at least nobody wasn't the
[ __ ] idiot bunny doesn't think it's
fun but he's still a [ __ ] idiot all
of you zip it it's like being on a bus
ride with a bunch of grade schoolers
they started it I swear to God money
movement sound Blanc is a division agent
yeah I can just make at the wristwatch
Galveston's Bonnie you're up find out
where he goes are you really gonna stick
me with stinky me to fly me here
last moaning for mobilising go go go
that's so hilarious by the time that the
agents from outside of the city had
arrived in Washington the majority of
the agents in the capital had gone mi a
presumed did part of the mission was to
find out what happened to them but
before that they had to put an end to
the growing hostile presence in the city
around this town there was a change of
plans
tomorrow's friends there's we can all
come out of this is teammates so much
the better you really think the division
doesn't seem reasonable to expect them
to keep doing their [ __ ] jobs the
division was doing their job for them
hostiles in the city were quickly being
dealt with this was gonna save a ton of
manpower and ammunition so for now the
black tusk could stay in the dark
allowing the division to push back the
three dominant factions who up until
this point had complete control of the
city so at this time the black tasks
continue to be unknown to the division
but continue to work out of site top of
their priority list was to get their
hands on a broad-spectrum antiviral
exactly medication that cures viral
sicknesses
in the way the antibiotics cure
bacterial sicknesses probably would have
been pretty useful seven or eight months
ago there were a couple different
broad-spectrum drugs and clinical trials
at the time but mass production was out
of the question
if they've been fast-tracked so where
did this one come from
Cillian Ann Arbor we're chasing that
down separately now your task is to
recover those doses that were shipped to
DC what are we gonna do with them
goddamnit use your imagination for who's
not gonna sell their son for a miracle
cure because of the ever-changing
adaptable nature of the green poison
this antiviral was deemed as an outright
cure for the virus though there was only
a limited supply the black tusk was
already dealing with the origin of this
cure but there was someone else with
information relating to the treatment
that would end it all and this person
was the president the president at this
time was Thomas Mendez he was sworn in
after President Lawrence Waller died
from a heart attack not long after the
original outbreak but it would seem that
this new president had trouble with the
newfound responsibility and committed
suicide
not long after taking the position the
situation is completely [ __ ] members
of The Secret Service had been promised
safe passage out of the city of a
limited mint is from the equation
perhaps he was unable to be controlled
in the way that the black tusks needed
or maybe this was the plan all along
maybe they were involved with prison
walls untimely death - but regardless
The Secret Service agents involved were
also removed as they were a potential
threat to the unveiling of the motives
of the black tusk
that guy was a disaster you think we can
hurry this up
got some wannabe text anywhere but here
you promised safe passage out of the
city you boys certainly earned
yourselves an express ticket out of this
predicament thank you God Brenner I had
to be sure president Ellis was the
Speaker of the House in the times of
Lawrence Wallace presidency and with the
deaths of Waller and Mendez he was sworn
in as the new president Ellis Andrews
considered putting in a bid for
presidency in the last election but
decided it wasn't the right time Ellis
aspires to build a new America
regardless of what it takes to achieve
this while aboard Air Force One it was
shot down over Washington DC airspace
[Applause]
that sounds about right gonna alter
course in the southeast heading one five
zero then come around and Parker sounds
good
it'll be good too wait a minute what's
that uh Andrews what are you reading
we've got a SAM evade evade copy that I
see it initiating evasive maneuvers [ __ ]
we're not gonna make it
Air Force one Air Force One
[Music]
[Applause]
presume did the division investigate the
area they found out that the hyenas had
captured president Ellis and taken two
mile stitch and were holding him in the
World Bank building after rescuing
prison Ellis and sending him back to the
safety of the White House he orders the
division to do what it takes to remove
the hostile factions and to retrieve
this missing briefcase with the codes to
the antiviral the division did as they
were instructed and pushed the dominant
factions of Washington's back into the
main headquarters and eliminated the one
by one after the destruction of the
hyenas outcasts and eventually the true
sons the division retrieved the
briefcase and returned it to President
Ellis however this was the moment the
black tusk had been patiently waiting
for while the division and the leaders
throughout Washington was celebrating
the success of overthrowing the hostile
factions who've been running the city
the black toss swooped in and captured
the city in one fell swoop
after fighting for weeks on him to take
down gangs cults and betrayers of the
government everything was quickly undone
by a superior force there had been
planning and studying for months before
finally showing their true force and
military power
end-game were first introduced to the
black tusk after we've finally taken
down the last of the hostile affections
shortly after this they roll in and take
control of the city on top of this
president Ellis disappears along the
briefcase containing access to the
antiviral cure in an eco we can see
Ellis passing the boss this is your baby
dad nothing gets near this container not
even a buckin squirrel you got me
understood
give me that satellite phone I want to
share the news myself go on it's obvious
through this Meetup that Ellis is not
the driving force behind the black tusk
he is merely another puppet under their
control and taken advantage of through
his vision of a new America Ellis has
disappeared with the briefcase has been
taken by Barton's crew to be extracted
via the Washington DC headquarters of
the tidal basin
the black tusk see the other factions is
merely a hindrance to the overall goals
the division and the civilian militia
their will to be dealt with if they
didn't succumb to the rule but in saying
that their sole potential to using them
to further their plans where they were
still in hiding from the toughest
subgroups Federation of [ __ ] pretty
much what about the true sons former
JTTF commander went bad started his own
private army they've been a dominant
group in DC for a while when it comes to
territory and firepower the oak ass
crazies that's very incisive Brunner
they survived a forced quarantine that
[ __ ] over pretty bad they're pissed
about it now they're on the rampage
typical terror style tactics mostly
dabbling in biological warfare what the
[ __ ] is wrong with people
like I said crazies well all the
divisions problem for the time being but
maybe we can destabilize the situation a
bit hyenas are probably the best bet
feed them some material support they'll
be a thorn in everybody's side and they
aren't organized enough to present a
serious problem in the long term good
recommendation Eli in an attempt to keep
the division busy where they continue to
work on their plants the black tusk
agreed to supply the hyenas with weapons
it's not that they trusted them they
just saw them as easier to control and
then remove from the time came another
puppet to their master plan
bharden passed on the antivirals to an
officer named Mila Reddick otherwise
known as women she was tasked with
getting the virals out of Washington
Riven is very professional detached and
coldly accepts setbacks and failures she
always follows orders
however as the division agents Roland
and take down a means of sending the
virus from the city she appears to lose
her composure towards the end of the
tidal basin stronghold she disobeys a
direct order from superior to retreat
instead she stays and tries to arm
missiles to blow up the White House
buttons deeply against us but she
continues to proceed but again the
division are able to fight her back and
destroy the missile launchers the
antivirals are retrieved and Washington
is once again safe the black tusk is
smart trained and well equipped they
also have the financial backing of an
organization that rivals the leadership
of the United States but the black tusk
an oblivious to the fact that they too
are being used as puppets and so on
else's game pulling strings on folks
that don't even realize they're puppets
pretty much guarantees a double-cross
then guys like us are a loose end for
people who don't want loose ends have
some thoughts about that things will
have sufficient leverage to come out
okay
I think he's envisioning us as the
praetorian guard of the new dynasty
don't forget we have ridiculous
firepower they understand the objectives
of their employer to create a new
dynasty and see themselves as a
potential loose in that will need to be
dealt with but through the superior
training and equipment they see
themselves as the new praetorian guard
amongst the new dynasty although they
may not be calling the shots it comes
down to them wither or be actioned
anyone familiar with the praetorian
guard at the roman period knows that it
ended up being them that helped the true
power in Rome
Empress Rosenfeld they come out but the
real questions of the story is who are
these employers of this they seem to
have been around since the beginning of
the outbreak and likely long before they
were prepared to employ this private
military contractor long before the
government knew how big a problem the
green poison was going to be were they
involved in some way with the outbreak
in the first place did they fund the
misguided goals of dr. Gordon Amherst
when he was first creating the virus to
me the story is far more interesting
than even the origins of the hunters I'd
even go so far to say that the hunters
are somehow connected with this group
but I'll talk about that more in a
future video
an obvious opposition to the government
to the highest degree they're even
willing to make a mockery of the
presidency to bend it to how they see
fit removing anyone that doesn't mix in
with their plants although the divisions
stopped the transportation of the
antiviral from the city this seems like
a minor blip on their overall radar I
feel as though anything the division has
managed to achieve so far has barely
altered the path that we give to C in my
opinion President Ellis is longer he's
either been removed completely as a
Lucent or has been held to be used as a
figurehead for a later movement on the
populace of the United States as you see
here I have a ton of questions that I'm
still trying to answer and I'm not
really expecting to know too much more
into a content like the upcoming raid is
released but I'll continue to read into
this story and see what I can find
do you have any theories on the employer
of the black tusk let us know below
anyway I'll leave this one here and
catch you in the next video Cheers
[Music]
you